for this
next caption contest i picked this
picture that you see
from the river walk in milwaukee of me
this is last winter on one of my many
walks
hanging out with the bronze fawns statue
which is kind of a
landmark here in milwaukee
and if you don't know who the fonz is he
was a major character
on the television show happy days here
you see him depicted by
henry winkler back in the day he was
kind of a cool guy
who wore a leather jacket and drove a
motorcycle
and did all sorts of things like hitting
the jukebox and making it play
and there's so much more to be told
about the story but i'm going to jump
right in
i also wanted to show you one other
picture this is
henry winkler the actor who played the
fawns
or arthur fonzarelli when the statue was
first
dedicated here in milwaukee on the
riverwalk you can tell how pleased he is
about that he actually is apparently a
very nice guy
fonzie is a nice but tough guy as a
character
and so it's you know kind of a cool shot
there so let's
jump right in here's a good caption
uh this one came in quite early sadler
just jumped the shark and lost
all credibility in the world of
family-friendly sitcom philosophy
so if you don't know this expression
jump the shark which we
use so often these days that actually
came from
happy days and it was fonzie who
jumped the shark quite literally he was
a
water skiing and they had this stunt
where he jumped over a shark
and at that point in time people were
like ah come on this is too much and so
that made its way
into our pop culture so saying that you
know i'm hanging out with fonzie
jumping the shark it's kind of a nice
meta way of bringing
things in here's another good one not
quite
sure what to make of it but it's kind of
a cool thing anyway philosophonzi
uh as opposed to philosopher uh
is fonzarella a real philosopher
he certainly had a lot of opinions on
things if you watch the show
some of which is good advice some of
which perhaps not
and so it's kind of a cool idea and then
we get to some
versus things right you got two
different people in the picture
so one could be one thing one could be
the other i don't know which one is
supposed to be which
so you have to decide that first one is
realism versus idealism
is it that i'm the idealistic one and
arthur fonzarella who's you know much
more of a
working guy uh you know hanging out in
in the pizza place or wherever it was
getting into his scrapes is more
realistic or is it that the statue
is idealized and i'm the one who's more
realistic i don't know
but here's another one me versus my
idealized
vision of myself now this is kind of
funny because
you know i grew up in the 70s and the
80s
when happy days was running
and i will tell you that there were
quite a few of us
who did take fonzie as kind of a role
model you know
and so i don't know that i would
actually call him an idealized version
of myself but you know by the time i was
in high school i wasn't a greaser
but i was a burnout wearing a leather
jacket
you know getting into tiffs with the
jocks
and all sorts of other things as well so
it's it's not as far off as you might
imagine
here's another one when popular culture
meets philosophical rigor i assume i'm
the one who's
representing philosophical rigor in that
case but i'm also somebody who
very much enjoys popular culture
especially those
things those elements of it based here
in the city that i love milwaukee
um you know is there any philosophical
rigor to happy days perhaps not i don't
know maybe somebody put out one of those
happy days and philosophy books by this
point in time i haven't researched it
but it'd be well worth
checking out or maybe there's some
interesting blog entries out there about
happy days and philosophy
now we start getting into philosophy
proper
man of gold meets a man of bronze
plato's republic
circa 350 bc colorized right so
presumably fonzie is the man of bronze
and i'm the man of gold since i'm a
philosopher
and if you don't know plato's references
here
so there's the three races um or maybe
four races depending on how you do it so
there's the gold the silver
and then the bronze perhaps iron as well
and the crafts people the people who do
their work with their hands are the
bronze the people who
rule because they are philosophers who
have
gone through a really rigorous education
and are devoted to the good of the city
or the
people of gold and this is part of a
myth so it's kind of cool that he
brings you know we can think about it
this way
pop culture is a whole bunch of myths
and plato
is is telling us that in his ideal city
which is a fictional thing we're gonna
tell the people this great lie
to make up this myth about uh metals
in ourselves now we get to some stuff
where it's
actually fonzie and and what he might be
saying so this is good a how you doing
mrs cunningham whoa don't touch the
leather greg you touch the leather you
touch the
fawns and that's that's really quite
good that's
that is in fact a line that was said
by fonzie and the leather is something
essential to him right mrs cunningham
was
uh one of the main characters in the
show as well fonzie hung out at their
place a lot of the time
here's another one that gets a little
bit more uh philosophical
you want to know the thing in itself up
absolum absum window
having trouble pronouncing it there
gregorelli then snapped his fingers and
thumps the critique of pure reason which
would be of course like the jukebox
it turns into the phenomenology of
spirit which somehow became magically
revised by his gesticulation so here
we're collapsing me
and the fawns together and talking about
some
uh characteristic things that he would
do
uh here's here's another one along these
lines here's
this is a line that fonzie would say you
ain't nobody until you do what you want
arthur herbert fonzarelli and then it's
counter posed to this
schopenhauer line a man can do what he
wants but not want
what he wants so you know we're starting
to get a little bit deeper into the
metaphysics of the will
and human nature with us all right so
last one japan's donkey sui
cool right somebody wrote that and then
tim keith came in and said
your bronze don't you sweet you mean so
bronze would be uh it was kind of funny
because that means
you tan there for you all right
but he's referring to the statue itself
uh being bronzed means you're somebody
and so i think that's kind of a cool
idea
we'll do more of these if you want to
get in on the next caption
contest while keep an eye on my social
media
and my youtube channel because i post
them i'll think about you know good pics
to post and
provoke people into writing these sorts
of things
and that's all for this one
you